side by side holding hands
a show of solidarity in munich
a human chain across the city protesting
against russia's invasion of ukraine
nearby the russian consulate its
entrance vandalized with red paint
a show of anger against vladimir putin
the man who protesters say must face
justice for his actions
i despise war any kind of war and i
really want to set an example i think
putin has been courted for far too long
for 20 years the west has been trying to
keep him quiet so that he doesn't get
upset and that simply has to stop now
in rome the mood may have been more
festive but the message to putin just as
critical
italy may have been one of russia's
closest allies in europe with many
politicians having previously boasted of
strong ties but now many are seeking to
distance themselves
across europe cities that have welcomed
russian money are having to reflect on
the effect that it's had on their
businesses and politics
among them london a major beneficiary of
russian cash since the end of the soviet
union but that has not calmed any
criticism of putin or his allies here
the more missiles raining down on
ukraine the more solidarity people here
are showing towards ukrainians and what
people here want is for the west to step
up and take decisive action against
putin
and his assault on ukraine there's going
to be a genocide why do we wait they
will go in
but only after there's a genocide how
outrageous
we need to do it now
in the hague home of the international
criminal court many called for an end to
the invasion and blamed putin himself
not russians for the conflict
all the while ukraine continues to come
under attack
yet many europeans are determined to
signal their support for the country and
to show ukrainians they are not alone
sonia gallego al jazeera london